hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 22 of my 02 100 Mil flipping
Series today we're starting off at about
uh well exactly
[Music]
I think we'll just put an offer in for
what we added in before and uh yeah I
mean we made four mil one flip we we
have to give these another try like it
just be kind of unethical not
to um and yeah we'll put an offer in for
we cannot afford six unfortunately but
we'll put an offer in for five and we'll
come back uh when hopefully we've sold
some of them okay so we actually did
manage to buy three anku socks um but
they are very slow um but we did sell
two of them already so we sold them for
a 366k profit which is pretty nice still
and two of those gives us 732k in profit
on this last ankus sock we're going to
have to sell for a bit less but that's
okay and um we also since we're getting
board we bought some um Samurai items
but we are just kind of waiting for them
to sell so we'll go um deal with those
later once they've actually sold okay so
the Elder chaos um Hood actually has a
or top sorry has a very good margin on
it it has about 120k uh so we'll go
definitely go buy 20 of
these and um we probably should get
another item as well um we'll check the
rest of the Elder chaos set cuz it
trades a lot and is very good um This
Hood actually has dropped a bit uh see
we can buy it for 800k no we cannot so
have to put a higher offer in okay so we
are going to do the eler chaos Hood
still is a very nice margin on it um for
the item it Stills about over 100k uh so
we'll go put an offer in for the rest of
our money and yeah we'll come back when
um the items have
sold Okay so we've sold pretty much uh
the majority of our stuff back so we
finally sold the Anu socks we ended up
getting a 400k margin in that so not too
bad did take a long time to sell uh the
Elder chaos tops we got pretty decent um
money from 74k on each one and 11 of
those gives us
814k uh the chaos hoods we broke even on
we sold them back for what we bought for
but still nothing ventured nothing lost
or whatever how you say that and uh
everything else we're just still kind of
waiting to sell um so we got about one
.2 mil from that flip so pretty decent
uh and yeah let's see what else we can
make okay so we're going to be
readjusting our Samurai boots uh cuz
they've been in there for way too long
so um we bought them for 261 so they've
dropped to
260 uh so the rest of these will be
selling at a very minor loss but uh we
won't be making anything
unfortunately uh the samurai Greaves I
mean we only have one I don't know if
it's worth actually checking that but
we'll just leave it for now
um Hill giant Club it's more expensive
than 1 mil for
sure okay so the obsidian Cape actually
has a 30k margin on it which is pretty
decent um so we're definitely going to
buy some of these they trade quite a lot
I mean it's used a lot so we'll go ahead
and buy
um maybe 30 or maybe a little bit more I
know we'll do 30 for now and we can go
back and change it after and we just put
an offer in for anku socks as well
um it's still been working pretty well
well I mean 400k on an item is still
quite nice um and we have 26 mil in our
inventory still so we're not quite sure
we're going to actually do with that yet
uh but anusak is quite a good item so we
might do one of these as well so we've
been looking at this ring of coins for a
little while now it cost I think 15 to
16 mil um
so yeah I'm going to give it a shot and
we'll just put an offer in that's like
good amount below the average price um
so
15.1 mil will'll do and see how that
works okay so we're back and um we
pretty much sold a good amount of our
stuff uh the obsidian capes we ended up
only getting a 7K margin on them so only
got about 100K in total from those uh we
didn't buy as many as we'd like the anko
socks we got a 200k margin so quite a
bit less as well uh but we didn't lose
any money we were selling most of these
Samurai boots back and unfortunately we
did not buy the Ring of coins
either um but I think we're going to try
it again um but we'll we'll buy some
other items first okay so the margin on
Anu socks that we just checked to be
sure it's
300K which is still not awful um they
just do take quite a while to buy and
sell um sometimes you only get like one
a day so it's I don't know we'll
probably just buy a couple of these but
we're going to save the most of our
money for doing another flip so instead
I think we're going to do a torso seed
flip had a 2K margin on it I believe um
put higher than that um but we can
afford 200 of these and um let's see
what it was yeah 2K pretty decent and
um yeah maybe we'll get one more item
going because you guys are asking for
some more cheaper items as well as the
expensive ones so maybe we'll toss some
other ones in there as well uh let's
check what Z skills is at least
141 and uh 139 yeah two GP on Z scales
very good so we'll definitely go do
those and uh we'll can't quite afford to
buy in limits worth which is
30,000 uh can do like half of that and
yeah we'll come back when the stuff has
sold okay so we're back and uh we didn't
make a whole lot of money the Ring of
coins we sold back for exactly what we
bought it for unfortunately so we didn't
lose any money um the anku socks we have
yet to buy um the zor scales we did get
a 2gp margin given us 30k and the Torso
seeds got us the most money
H about
175k uh so not too bad but uh we're
going to move on to some more expensive
items I think uh we're going to check
the Ring of coins margin just straight
up so we bought for
15632 and we sell it for
15350 so a 300K margin on an item this
expensive isn't that great but it does
trade a lot more than the anku set a lot
more than the other Master clue
items um so we might put an offer in for
a couple cuz that's all we can actually
afford um we'll start off with two and
see where that goes okay so we might try
these Dragon bolts we bought them for uh
2K each and we're selling them for 18853
so about 150 GP on each uh which is is
quite good um we just have to see how
many we can actually buy of
these um we'll probably just use the
rest of our money because they do have a
11k limit something around there um so
we'll just yeah max out the rest of our
money on this and we'll see how that
goes and we'll come back when uh we
bought and sold a couple things okay so
we did actually manage to buy the Ring
of coins this time we flipped them for a
259k profit on each one so relatively
not very good for the cost of the item
but we still got over 500k from profit
from that um the dragon bolts that we
only got about 60k from um but I think
that's what we're going to call it the
end of the episode we didn't get a whole
lot of progress this week um we spent a
lot of time working on our other series
but of course my channel is flipping old
school so we're going to continue on
with the flipping of course I still
really enjoy it it was just a bit of a
slow week um but still we started about
39.8 mil and we're ending at
about
41 mil pretty close to 41 mil so we
didn't get a whole lot of money we still
got 1 mil which isn't that bad but um
next week we'll definitely pick up our
game so hope you guys enjoyed and I'll
see you guys on the next episode
[Music]